[Music]
hey what is up guys in cabbie HD here
welcome to 2017 and every year has some
type of trend that all the big
smartphones that get released that year
tend to follow whether it's material
related or battery related or headphone
jack related so I was thinking about
what this would be the year of what 2017
would be and the first thing that came
to my mind was dual cameras most of the
top smartphones all the way down have
adopted at some point during this year
dual cameras with a couple notable
exceptions like Galaxy s8 from earlier
this year all the Motorola stuff and
likely pixel to later this year but
everything else Galaxy Note 8 iphone 8
new phones from new companies new phones
from old companies dual cameras were
everywhere in smartphones this year but
something interesting is they all did it
for a slightly different variety of
purposes
iPhone for example did one normal lens
and one 2 X optical zoom lens so a
portrait lens but also great for zooming
in LG g6 did one normal lens one super
wide angle zoom so a landscape lens but
also you know great for some fun fisheye
effects essential phone was one that had
a normal camera and one monochrome
camera for enhanced detail in every shot
but also great black and white photos if
you want and so all these different
methods of utilizing dual cameras in the
back of a smartphone have been spread
across these manufacturers for the past
year or two but what we're really seeing
is this year 2017 is the year of the
disappearing bezels it's every single
smartphone that we've looked forward to
during the course of this year has had a
minimization of the bezels in some point
and even the ones we're looking forward
to for later this year smaller bezels
and to be fair they've all done that in
slightly different ways over the past
couple months as many people are willing
to point out no phone is truly
completely bezel lists there are things
that you need to put on the front of a
phone so the front facing camera the
proximity sensor the ambient light
sensor of some display drivers etc so as
everyone minimizes the bezel they all
have to decide what to do with those
couple of things that have to stay on
the front of the phone and it's been
really interesting to watch the
essential phone that's just starting the
ship has crunched the earpiece speaker
and notification LED way up in the
top sliver of the phone and use a cutout
of the top of the display for the
front-facing camera and sensors the
bottom chin is just for the display
drivers LGG 6 and galaxy s 8 and even
Samsung's Note took a more even approach
of having symmetrical slim bezels where
they put all the front-facing stuff and
the speakers and sensors up at the top
and they match that size with the bottom
bezel but they have almost zero side
bezels and then have phones like the
Xiaomi me mix from a couple months ago
with that incredible floating display
look they chose a piezoelectric speaker
vibrating the frame instead of a
standard earpiece and they moved all the
front-facing sensors to the bottom chin
so this thing has truly 0 top and side
bezels and got a lot of attention for it
so all that has gotten us here and I've
said this before cheap phones are
getting good and good phones are getting
cheap this phone I landed here a couple
days ago the do G do G dougie
Doge Doge Doge e Duke the Duke prop the
do geek phone the do G mix this thing is
a $200 budget smartphone that emulates a
more premium flagship look and a lot of
those key ways including the smaller
bezels on the front and the dual cameras
on the back it also happens to have an
octa-core chip and six gigs of RAM so
it's gunning hard out of nowhere for
budget smartphone of the year which is
really impressive I think it falls short
in the places where you can tell they're
cutting corners though obviously no USB
type-c no wireless charging no
waterproof but mostly just generally
missing a lot of the fit and finish the
premium that make flagships so nice to
hold this thing helps us see the
difference honestly between a low budget
bezel slicking phone and a super
high-end bezels phone at the core of it
this has the exact same shape and
silhouette look as another bezel this
phone like the essential for example but
when you take a closer look you know you
turn the display on it really still does
have a pretty decent sized side bezel
and top bezel I mean the display doesn't
really reach all the way up into the
corners
like you'd expect and the spots all the
way around the phone where the glass the
display glass meets the body and the
back glass meets the side it's a bit
sharper its
we rounded a little bit which is great
but when you take Samsung's new flagship
for example the rounded edges of the
glass practically melt over into the
side rails of the body and then back
over into the back glass again so it
makes a big difference when holding it
in the hand I didn't always used to be
like that
I remember the galaxy s7 edge was really
sharp around the edges and that didn't
go very well but that's the kind of
thing you're getting for the price now
so though this phone this do G mix for
two hundred bucks
has been really impressive and if you
can get past the pretty cartoonish skin
on top of Android it is actually worth a
look and I'll drop a link below if
you're into it but look the more I look
into it the more I realize the real
reason why this is the year of the
disappearing bezels in smartphones is
because that has had an effect that
nothing else has had on the entire
history of smartphones and they're doing
something they've never done in the past
decade which is getting smaller the main
benefit of shrinking the bezels around
the display is to shrink the body size
and shrink the footprint of the
smartphone so these are handheld devices
and that matters a lot for usability
being able to reach the corners fitting
the thing in your pocket etc this is the
first year we're actually expected to
see a flagship iPhone that's smaller in
every dimension than the previous year
but with a bigger display that's why
it's special so I just wanted to
articulate that on video and for the
holiday rush of smartphones we're about
to see Galaxy Note 8 and then LG v30
iPhone 8 Google pixel to keep an eye out
for that keep an eye out for the
shrinking disappearing top bottom and
side bezels and enjoy it because we have
no idea what's next thanks for watching
talked to you guys the next one peace
[Music]